welcome back and a surprising move the
union that represents ice officers has
launched a new website claiming that
President Trump has quote betrayed them
the national ice council endorsed Donald
Trump in the 2016 election but the group
is now upset that the Trump
administration has been really slow to
reverse the policies of the Obama years
a post on the website reads in part
quote while officers view the
president's position on enforcement as
courageous the Trump administration has
left all of the Obama managers and
leadership in place tensions are on the
rise between Trump's army and Obama
holdovers so joining us now for reaction
from Orlando David Ward a board member
of the National Association of former
Border Patrol officers and here in
Washington Stephen Dinan reporter with
the Washington Times who wrote about
this today
Stephen this is odd but it's something
we've heard about in other departments
what is the percentage of Obama
holdovers still working within
immigration Customs Enforcement yeah so
the ice council didn't say the number
and they actually didn't even name names
they left it vague for now but they they
went through a number of different
issues the website is websites actually
fascinating not only does it give this
sort of overall sense for the Obama
holdovers it gives a whole bunch of
different specific examples of where
those are having an effect including an
incident in Philadelphia where ice
officers who went into a very bad
neighborhood of Philadelphia we're told
they had to remove their bulletproof
vests to go make an arrest because it
would offend the community where they
were going into it offends them David it
offends the ice officers does it not
when they get shot because they're not
wearing a bulletproof vest for fear that
it will offend I guess one of the
illegal immigrants I mean what are we
talking about here this is insanity
it is insanity we've lost over 160 to
immigration agents killed in the line of
duty
and for a manager to come up with a
order such as that to take off their
bulletproof vests because they're going
into a neighborhood is absolutely insane
in fact that manager or those people
involved and that should be removed from
their office for
competency do we have any idea David how
many Obama holdovers are clogging the
you know the administration here at at
the immigrations custom enforcement and
the website is very fuzzy on this we
don't know how many is it is it twelve
is it five hundred I mean what are we
talking about what well the Trump
administration has been in office for
eleven months now and you know the swamp
is pretty big and its vast within the
federal government is going to take time
to weed out those that are sworn to
their office as the oath that they took
those that have sworn to the globalism
which brought us sanctuary cities and
lack of enforcement of title eight and
it's going to take a while to weed those
people out Stephen let's talk about how
the priorities of President Trump and
Obama do differ whether whether you have
the right people in place yeah that's
infuriating but I remember the ice
officers during Obama's two terms the
morale was horribly low because they
wanted to do their job and they were
held back ya know and there's no
question in fact I think there's not a
single department and probably not a
single agency other than ice where
there's been as big a change in the
culture between the Obama administration
and the Trump administration as you look
we actually did calculations under the
Obama administration upwards of 80
percent of illegal immigrants were put
out of bounds for deportation because of
the priorities that the administration
the previous administration set out now
the the number is probably closer to
only about a million basically daca
recipients are the folks who are put
completely out of bounds and the rest of
the 11 million illegal immigrants are at
least potential targets for deportation
it's made a huge difference for those
ice officers that we're talking about
and they'll admit they're thrilled with
that sort of the overall direction that
they're getting from president of
President Trump the issue is that the
actual specific decisions such as the
Philadelphia when we talked about
there's a case out of Utah where they
are told they have to give heads up
before they go into the community and
what in some cases 7 days heads up
before they go out to make arrests lo
and behold when they finally get there
the illegal immigrants they're targeting
have been tipped off and have basically
fled so those are the sorts of specifics
that they would like to get cleaned up
they absolutely appreciate the
difference in the in the top-down
direction David I remember a couple of
years back when the Border Patrol is
different from the ice officers but the
Border Patrol under Obama were told that
they they couldn't shoot at a vehicle
that was attempting to run them down
that was one of the other crazy things
and again here they are they don't make
a lot of money they're trying to do
their job it's very dangerous and often
times they're in very remote areas but
in other other cases they're actually
being targeted by the illegal immigrants
who are trying to get into the country
because they're all valedictorians I
know that but they're trying to come to
the country and they're and I guess the
ice officers just have to jump out of
the way and hope for the best are they
dead Border Patrol officers under the 8
years of the previous administration and
immigration of force became probably the
most dysfunctional I'd seen it in 34
years of working for the agency and
enforcing immigration law now when Trump
came into office the apprehension rate
went up 37 percent in the first four
months by these agents being allowed to
do their jobs that they took an oath to
do and now we need to get the managers
in there that are gonna back these men
up under the same guidelines by standing
up for their their oath that they took
and follow the law title 8 is very clear
Trump has been criticized about creating
things when he in fact he hasn't
it's the immigration law that's been on
the books from day one the Democrats the
previous administration refused to go by
jeh Johnson was loathe to even read the
book that let alone let the guys go out
and do their jobs so we have an
administration now I would say that it's
going to take a little bit of time to
clean out the swamp like keys for trying
to do but another thing he's faced with
the obstruction of Congress in the
Senate I'm getting his appointees into
office Stevens we're out of time on that
but he has to get his people in place
he's not gonna eliminate all the
positions he has to get his people in
place